uh thank you yes sir I'm so happy to
welcome today Trent Colquitt and
Associate at cubic and what I learned
that is the award-winning gift shop at
the world chairs Hall of Fame welcome
Trent thank you so much for having me
yes please tell us a little bit about
the history of Q Boutique and what are
your best sellers there oh awesome well
once again thanks for having me the Q
Boutique is uh located inside the world
chest Hall of Fame and it is associated
with that as well so it has chess
related items such as pieces and DVDs
and books to help with chess but we're
all considered an all-season Boutique as
well so we have tons of other things
that will specialize for any guests
whether puzzles or games uh even cards
for like those those hard to gift people
so we have tons of those things as well
actually those
for me tough for me because I want to
buy literally everything especially well
as a professional chess player I want to
to have all those things at home
there is always a new apparel for a
tournament please tell us about your
Novelties for the Cairns Cup oh awesome
yeah so typically for every single
tournament we have custom apparel
whether it is a t-shirt or a hat or
something to represent each of the
tournaments that we have here at Q
Boutique or here at the chess club as
well uh so for the Karen's cup we will
have some autograph boards and some uh
posters as well from the from the
tournament participants and I've also
learned rumor has it that you have a few
unique gifts at your cubic so tell me a
little bit about those so maybe sign
chess boards yeah and that's for every
tournament as well so for every
participant of every tournament that we
have we do have signed chess boards we
do also have some signed posters from
time to time but we do also have tons of
custom apparel you can get all of that
online as well as our brick and mortar
location
also I invite all of you guys to visit
Saint Louis and cubic I'm pretty sure
that we are going there on the free day
so we'll find something new thank you so
much and well
one question how well do you play chess
and do you follow the tournament daily
so we're gonna have the boutique we do
get to follow a lot of the live stream
so that's been really cool uh I started
playing probably around seven years old
so I've been playing a little bit I'm
still on the amateur level so I couldn't
take on any of these awesome ladies
today but uh I definitely enjoy watching
it and yeah that's one of the biggest
reasons that I work at the boutique now
so oh it's impressive thank you very
much thank you so much back to you yes
sir actually Trent we got a question
from a social media or maybe it was just
the ladies a lot of the
um participants in the Karen's cup have
been wearing their swag and the question
was could could normal people uh buy the
same hoodies that the ladies were
wearing
uh so what was that of the hoodies well
they were they're wearing uh these uh
the Karen's uh jackets oh yeah
absolutely yes they are available online
at our Bricker motor location so it's a
cubeboutique stl.com oh yeah we were
told that they were exclusive
I told you they were exclusive
all right thank you Trent thank you for
joining us thank you thank you so much
right okay well now we know
I think you're asking because you want
one for yourself well you know there are
and special ladies in my life but uh
that if I come home empty-handed you
know I don't know how it works